[Music]
hey what's up mkbhd here and today was
the first apple event of the calendar
2021 year another virtual one and
another pretty action-packed one the
spring loaded title was well deserved so
this video is me breaking down and
reacting to all three of the major
announcements because there were three
and each of the three was very different
from the other
also this video is sponsored by
expressvpn so for more info on that stay
tuned to the end but i'll also have a
link below on how to get three months
for free so today was april 20th 4 20.
and it was a very busy 4 20. the apple
event was filled with a lot of great
transitions per usual at this point it
feels like i have to watch the keynotes
once for the new products then one more
time for the key specs and all the facts
and information and then one more time
for the cinematography it's really good
like how is our audio so good where are
their mics how are they that stable on a
boat in the middle of the bay but anyway
at the end of the day we have three new
major announcements
air tags
m1 imacs
and m1 ipad pros
there's chapters below if you're that
impatient but let's just start with air
tag shall we this was the the one that
we were looking forward to for the
longest time they were rumored forever
it was just a question of when apple was
actually going to release them so now
they're unveiled and this is air tags so
they're a little quarter-sized puck that
connects two iphones find my network so
you can find them anywhere and they have
a little speaker built in so you can
ping them and they'll make a noise but
the main way you'd find them is the same
way you'd use find my iphone or find my
mac then when you're within bluetooth
range the ultra wideband u1 chip in
iphone 11 or iphone 12 will show you
exactly how far away it is and where to
look and guiding you to finding it
simple but super useful air tags just
make a lot of sense and this find my
network has been so useful for so long
because it it runs off the backs of
everyone else's iphones so when someone
passes by an air tag that's been lost it
passively updates the location of that
air tag in the background and it just
keeps everybody's stuff on the map if
you will um also if someone finds a lost
air tag they can touch their iphone to
it and it'll show a name and a phone
number and they can get in touch with
you if that was yours so they'll cost uh
29 bucks for one or 99 bucks for a four
pack
which i was thinking about it that's not
it's not that bad that's right about the
same price as the cheapest tiles but
it's just super
well integrated like if you were picking
between this and any other if you have
an iphone
this is in the ecosystem actually my
main question would be what would you
find with them to justify a four pack i
feel like they were really smart about
doing four instead of three so if i had
four
keys are the obvious one
um backpack for me would be the other
and then maybe
maybe a pet collar or something like
that or you could give one to a spouse
or something like that it's pretty slim
1.25 inches tall and weighs 11 grams so
i feel like you can kind of put it
anywhere a tile could go it's ip67 water
resistant it's made of metal and apple
will let you engrave that metal if
you're into that with a couple letters
or an emoji but the real customization
is in the color of the band you choose
to put it in also what why is the hermes
version so expensive i'm sorry i've
never known how exactly to pronounce
that but the fact that it's literally 10
times the price of the normal
sleeve for the mermaid whatever it's
called i
wow but also worth noting the spec also
lists a user replaceable
cr2032 battery
which is pretty nice um that's the same
type of battery you might have in a
watch or a garage door opener one of
those circular batteries
um
which is not the case for all of these
find my devices some older tiles didn't
have user replaceable batteries so when
they died
you just
that was it they were dead you have to
buy another one
newer tiles i use replaceable but that's
pretty sweet i could easily have seen
apple being the company that went the
opposite route and said we made a shiny
metal one you can't take the battery out
they didn't
nice but yeah i'll definitely be getting
my hands on air tags asap to show you
how they work what that experience is
like how well you can actually find
things with them and whether or not
they're worth the money so definitely
subscribe to see that video if you
haven't already
all right next up we gotta talk about we
got to talk about these imacs so all the
colorful teasers leading up to this
event we're kind of hinting at new
colorful imacs right maybe it's
hindsight 2020 but it was clearly a
throwback to the original colorful imacs
that came out many years ago so here
they are now it's 20 21 and the first
colorful apple desktops and a long timer
here this new imac redesign in seven
very bright colors red orange
yellow blue
aqua green and silver so the gist here
is these are completely redesigned imax
from the ground up as you can probably
already tell and they have m1 ships
inside so there's new performance new
internals and then a new outside
that i
don't like very much like to me okay
this imac design is actually super
impressive technically speaking right
it's got the squared off design now just
like the pro display xdr the tilt
adjustable hinge on the back
and it is crazy thin
crazy thin 11 and a half millimeters
and the whole thing is 10 pounds which
is insane that's about the same
thickness as an apple watch two air tags
stacked on top of each other thicker
than the whole computer believe it or
not fun fact this imac is so thin
that you actually can't plug in
headphones
from the back anymore because a typical
headphone jack is 14 millimeters deep
and the whole computer is 11 millimeters
deep so they put the headphone jack on
the side now
at least they kept it
i actually think the size is better but
there is a larger 24 inch 4480 by 2280
display up front that gets closer to the
edges and also now has white bezels for
some reason and there's still a pretty
solid metallic chin that now has no logo
on it and it matches the color of the
back of the imac and the base
and the sides are actually a different
accent color than the back and the chin
so basically the red imac will have a
red body and red sides but a
salmon-colored chin and stand it's an
interesting two-toned look they've got
going on
and then the insides are completely
redesigned around that m1 chip now we
already knew the m1 chip was great in
the macbook air and the baseline macbook
pro but also in the mac mini so it makes
perfect sense that well there's actually
tons of room inside this imac to
continue to be great plus they've
dropped an improved camera system and
speaker system in here
but apple actually showed the inside of
the imac and just look at this thing
most of the computer is just in those
tiny pieces down at the bottom and like
a slot basically where that chin is the
rest is all thermals and ribbon cables
they also made some color matching
accessories like this magic mouse and
track pad and a new magic keyboard that
has a touch id fingerprint reader in the
corner very cool
uh
but just
it's ugly
right i'm not crazy am i this replaces
the 21.5 inch intel imac
and there's got to be a larger 27-inch
imac replacement coming with like an m1x
chip or something and i feel like that
version has got to have a way smaller
chin
and way less crazy colors again this
machine despite me thinking it's pretty
ugly is technically
very impressive being this thin fitting
a whole computer in such a thin profile
getting dolby atmos supporting speakers
in there the performance of the m1 the
instant wake all that great stuff that
comes from the m1 chip that is super
great the power adapter that it comes
with plugs in magnetically into the back
with a color matching cable and there's
an ethernet plug on the brick of at
least some of the specs so you don't
have to have a cable that runs all the
way up to your desk
four usb c ports on the back two of
which are thunderbolt 3.
i wish there was an sd card slot but it
looks like there isn't one also there
are only two ports if you buy the
cheapest model but the fact is i saw
this and it was really cool to see
colored imacs again but this imac is
only really pretty
from the back like you you get it out
the box and you're obviously like wow
this is super thin you put it on your
desk then you never see the back again i
have no idea how thick these monitors
are i also don't really care two inches
three four inches i don't really care so
i personally think it would have made a
ton of sense for apple to put most of
this computer stuff
behind the display instead of in the
huge chin and make this imac a bit
thicker right now it's literally half an
inch thick maybe make it one inch thick
i don't know one and a half it would
still look great it would still be very
thin but it would look way better
without that chin oh and then turn the
bezels back to black while you're at it
please i'm never gonna get a real answer
about why exactly they did it this way
maybe it was thermals that they couldn't
put it back there
i don't know
but what i'm pretty sure of is that
that's exactly what they're gonna do
with a higher end
m1x 27-inch imac that comes out probably
later this year that higher-end
redesigned version
will probably look much better because
at the end of the day keep this in mind
this bright beautiful new imac we're
looking at
is just replacing the baseline 21 and a
half inch model which was not
very up to date there were people
complaining about you know it maxes out
at 512 gigs of storage
the one it's replacing maxed out at 256
gigs of solid-state storage then it
would do like a one terabyte fusion
drive so this is actually a much better
computer than the 1080p
outdated 21.5 inch imac that it replaces
but i feel like there's no way future
higher end apple silicon imacs look like
this with the white bezels in the chin
i'm just saying
also i was scrolling through the site
just like looking through the design and
if you get to just the right point on
the page it's at this moment where it's
like changing colors
and it looks like this kind of split
tone imac and it looks actually pretty
sweet but you can't buy a split tone
imac i'm sure dbrand's already on top of
this but anyway last but certainly not
least was the third and final big
announcement which was the new m1
powered ipad pros
which again are
very
technically impressive because you know
the thing we are all worried about with
the ipad pros is
are they too slow
not really but this new ipad pro is in
the same familiar design still just as
thin and impressive and unibody metal as
ever but it's now powered by that crazy
powerful and efficient m1 chip and this
is
super curious to me the a12z bionic was
already pretty incredible for the ipad
pro and it was optimized for a device
with that thermal profile and with that
battery the m1 chip in an ipad just
seems like huge overkill so this is now
an even more powerful tablet than ever
before widening their gap and the m1
chip now also means that the usb-c port
at the bottom is now a full-on
thunderbolt port for those high speeds
there's now up to two terabytes of mac
storage on the ipad pro which is massive
and it gets 5g support on top of that
already pretty useful cellular option
and then the larger only the larger 12.9
inch ipad pro gets upgraded to a mini
led display so this is something we're
also looking forward to for a while some
of us were secretly hoping for oled
the ipad pros have been 120 hertz lcds
for a little bit this is probably just
as good so now this 120hz display will
have 1600 nits max brightness and hdr
supports the full p3 color gamut and
there's about 2600 local dimming zones
for hopefully some really deep inky
blacks and sharp high contrast bright
scenes but i'm really looking forward to
seeing what that mini led ipad pro looks
like versus the lcds we've seen but it
should be great for things like photo
editing whatever video editing you might
be doing on the ipad but also especially
watching movies because let's face it a
lot of movies on ipads have the black
bars at the top and the bottom those
should be even darker since pixels are
off
even more inky blacks when watching
movies so should be a pretty good
upgrade i'm just super curious if we're
actually going to notice a performance
difference between
the a12z
and the m1 chip in an ipad pro i mean
it's it's just ipad os at the end of the
day
and it's going to be doing processing
and maybe those types of compilation
times are faster but will battery life
be better
the ipad pro actually has a bigger
battery than the macbook airs but you
know it's 120 hertz display so it
balances out i don't know we'll have to
test we'll have to see but hey at the
end of the day even if this thing is
nuclear powerful
it's still an ipad
so it's going to be amazing at all the
things that ipads were already pretty
good at but also just as limited so i
mean this there's nothing i'd like more
than to try
final cut pro on a small
3k touchscreen with an m1 chip but
i can't because ipad but hey at least
good on apple for not resting on their
30 million light year lead on
performance specifically in tablets but
yeah that's basically it those are the
three big new bullet points there was
also some other small stuff announced at
this event there's a new apple tv 4k
and there's also a new remote for the
apple tv which is nice there's also a
new purple iphone 12.
so mid cycle refresh stuff
honestly i probably will end up making a
video on that we'll see
but those are the those are the main
things and my reactions and my thoughts
to them anyway let me know in the
comments what you guys think of the
announcements but specifically do you
also think the new imac is as ugly as i
do
because i seriously
anyway uh there's a lot of other
hands-on and more videos on this sort of
stuff coming up so if you want to see
that if you want to see air tags in
action if you want to see a purple
iphone but if you want to see the new
ipad pros and m1 imacs be sure to
subscribe so you can be first in line to
see that stuff hit the bell even while
you're down there
anyway
thanks for watching now a word from the
sponsor shout out to the sponsor of
today's video expressvpn so some of you
like to pause and take note of the apps
on my phone during videos so some of you
have already seen expressvpn on my phone
i've been using it for uh more than two
weeks now i've actually tried other vpns
in the past because resvpn is now my
go-to it's the fastest one i've used and
it's obviously very secure so i know
we're all kind of spending a lot more
time online than ever before so the
thing is when you are browsing from your
own home your internet service provider
you know whether that's comcast or
verizon whoever it is can see every
single site you visit even when you're
in incognito mode and you're hiding it
from google theoretically they can still
see everything you visit and they can
sell that information legally so with
expressvpn it reroutes your connection
through secure encrypted servers
elsewhere so they can't see what sites
you're visiting nobody can so anytime
your device connects to the internet
that data is safely encrypted and then
the cherry on top expressvpn lets you
choose the location of those servers
to make it look like you are from that
location so that lets you access content
that's not available in your region by
making it look like you're from another
region so you can access thousands of
new shows that are on netflix or bbc
iplayer like i've been watching a lot of
top gear episodes that are specifically
only available in bbc iplayer so with
expressvpn i changed my location to the
uk and now i can watch that stuff so
unlock thousands of new shows and
content and protect your privacy with
expressvpn and of course if you hit the
link in the description and use my code
you can get your first three months free
at expressvpn.commqbhd
so link below check it out that's for
you thanks for watching this video
catch you in the next one
peace
you